foreign  and so I went to Leo and I go well look  here's the deal here's what I want  here's what I think we need to do we  need to have you go into the trailer and  have a freak out  and  I want to write it I think I think it  has to be improvised I think I'll give  you a whole bunch of subjects  for you to be freaking out about  um  but we'll come up with this uh we'll  we'll take our little trailer set and  then I'll uh uh I'll put a camera I'll  never change the angle I'll just do it  with jump Cuts just think about uh  Travis pickles the sequence in his  apartment for a taxi driver so you won't  have to worry about matching anything  you just go off and have uh we'll do  three tirades and we'll just run the  camera until the in until the footage  Runs Out